oh wow hi it's me Trixie Mattel today
I'm gonna help you make a sandwich
that's gonna be so delicious even Martha
Stewart I want to put herself back in
shackle but first we need a shot Wow
goes down easy
I'm gonna teach you how to make peanut
butter and jelly come gonna be honest
with you I'm a vegetarian I don't really
know how to make a goddamn single other
things so bread is a good start
bread is great bread is a car but I
prefer crunchy peanut butter because um
it reminds me that I still have teeth I
don't have a bottle opener I'm just
kidding perfect I like a lot of peanut
butter because to me it's kind of like
the whole fantasy we're gonna do this
the way the Chinese read which is right
to left is that right it's Arabic
oh is it exhausting knowing everything
strawberry premiums I'm gonna get this
up crouching helps oh I thought the
bread was gonna be soft look at that I
guess I am gonna slam them together
today I'm feeling very dramatic this is
um adversity and this is you and this is
you overcoming your adversity ah
does anybody here actually like crusts I
mean life is short do you want to spend
it eating the burnt perimeters of bread
and these nobody eats those we don't
even use those so I like to do a
triangle it's really about presentation
when you're making something this stupid
whoo so you are a homo and you are in a
wig in your kitchen so you got to kind
of like up the drum a little bit this is
some edible glitter you can get this at
7-eleven that's how you get you a man I
wouldn't know but they're toothpicks
this is pepper [ __ ] mmm and then you
don't want your sandwiches to fall apart
that way when your ham-fisted kids are
trying to scarf these down they're not
gonna choke you guys thought I was gonna
[ __ ] that up I'm gonna call it the
peanut butter and don't be jelly this is
just basically a catalyst for the drink
so now you've had your dinner and now
you can have your after your cocktail
glass is a good start
it's a portable icing drug because in
the ice melts you have more drink this
is Malibu rum so this drink is called
the barbie girl and it's really
beautiful because it's bright pink it's
super girly you like whoo I couldn't
open peanut butter but I can open a
booze bottle like what I'll do is I'll
put a splash in and then when everyone
leaves the room a lot more in so now we
need an ounce of vodka I don't get too
drunk nowadays though that was for me if
you saw me 2 v 2 my makeup I look like
Wilson from castaway now we're gonna get
some of the color movie sent on with you
guys but I'm gay enough that a drink has
to taste good it also has to look good
we're also gonna put an ounce of
cranberry juice in here
I don't know oh my god this is like the
movie Carrie let me kill myself with a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich is this
an alcoholic Ouija board we also need an
ounce of orange juice pineapple juice
you're gonna need a fruit garnish it's
so important to have another cutting
board and a knife I had to run to my
bedroom to get this one end of the line
you cut off the other end of the line
you have it and then you go in and do
little like that if you want to talk
about how to drink you ask a drag queen
this is missing something it's missing a
little fun make it a little more gay and
oh that's fun Oh little toys right I'm
gonna line this up here I like that so
that's the drink for your friend now
this is where it gets serious I'm gonna
show you how to make the drink for you
more ice I'm just gonna go in and we're
gonna make the same drink
we're gonna eliminate any of the drama
fruit juice ism' I know what you're
thinking oh my god they're gonna know
right away they turn out drinking the
same drink follow me here food coloring
so I'm looking at this I see pink I see
orange so I'm gonna go in here
oh yes now we're cooking with gas
okay well this is already different did
you guys figure out that I don't know
what I'm doing you know what we're gonna
do what my parents did we're gonna make
ends meet look at that who's the wiser
[Music]
tada
and now you're like oh my god I'm just
having one drink I'm being good tonight
meanwhile you're seeing Jesus's eyes and
the real gag is they're both for you
thank you for joining me my kitchen by
the way when you go to a bar don't you
ever [ __ ] ask for this drink you get
a vodka soda or like a Jack and Coke
like everybody else nobody wants to fix
you Manhattan nobody wants to make you a
[ __ ] blended margaritas it's your
birthday nobody cares